wow so you do the fleshlight short
right lightning short right it does
it's it's good right because i had heard
of it
and then all of a sudden you got an
agent from that right
and then you were able to go into real
rooms and picture [ __ ]
yeah that was like got me the first like
i did generals everywhere
from that short and while still an
assistant which was intense so i had to
schedule the meetings like perfectly so
an intern could cover the phones while i
like went and
amazing dude amazing but then how did
dip do
so dip dip came from uh you know
from 2011 to like 2012 i'm just reaching
out to bands and making music videos for
them like finding their instagram or
their manager's instagram and like
bombarding them
and then um i stumbled into a bar and
saw this band necrogoblicon play my
neighbor and my good friend randy was
like you want to come see this band
necrogoblicon i was like yeah sure why
not
i love everything and the goblins are
scary
oh you ever heard a necrogoblicon
it's like a metal band but the lead
singer
is a goblin
it's incredible can you pull up a
picture of the lead singer
of necrogoblicon
dude this is that's them dude it's
[ __ ] incredible
that's easy he reminds me of he reminds
me of the goblin that
tortures frodo look at his face holy
[ __ ]
oh my god that's amazing this is just
hang on a second
imagine i like his friends hold on hold
on a second back up a little bit
imagine if that's really a goblin
you imagine if a goblin became a rock
star and everybody thought it was cute
but it really was a [ __ ] gobbling you
need to watch the video
bro the makeup's amazing he never takes
it off
and he's a real [ __ ] god okay
well that's the whole deal like the his
biggest song is like he has a normal job
and he has a crush on this girl
oh my god but she's in love with this
like douche bag
from the office oh my god these are
blowing
powder on people what is happening here
i've never seen this video dude just
imagine if that was real
because of an alien comes down like with
cgi um we're listing the album on the
way there and i was like man this is so
technical and masterfully written this
is either gonna be like one guy in his
computer or like 12 bohemoth
[ __ ] just like and we walk in there
and it's just
seven dudes masterfully playing this
music but they just look like dudes and
i thought it was so funny their
commitment
to writing these intense songs about
goblins like i want to make a music
video for you and they're like yeah
we've heard that all before
like we don't want to dress up we're not
gore and i took a trip to chicago
and i i visited my mom in wisconsin on
the drive back and i sat at pippen's bar
and i just like
this this character like spewed out at
me and i wrote it i pitched the band
they're like yeah let's do it we have no
money so i reached out to like 80 brands
relentlessly like here's who i am here's
my previous videos but and i got three
to pay for it
and we put it out i didn't i didn't
think anything was gonna come from it
but on like the third or fourth date it
was on the front page of reddit
and then the day after that diplo just
tweeted the word necrogoblicon
and then i got in touch with his manager
and yeah
bro that's a great bro hustle
bro bro i got the chill bumps on my
[ __ ] skin right oh
yeah i'm getting teary-eyed because i'm
gonna say something to you all right
this isn't a dude right that that sits
idle that's nepotism
this isn't a dude that comes from
hollywood royalty
right this is a dude that went to
colombo columbia university
right came out here waited i mean
what couldn't wait tables hosted it
couldn't wait hosted
at places right and but what i love
about it is
is that it's a guy that everything that
you have
right wasn't handed to you you are the
one
because for imagine making phone calls
to [ __ ] you know
companies going hey can i i don't even
know who to call pr
pr department you know i mean hi you
know
imagine doing all the footwork that you
need to do
and it's so funny about him because
if you look back at diplo when i told my
agent no
right that wasn't enough for him
he went to andy andrew santino and go
dude you gotta
make the call convince him right most
people are like oh we'll have to find
somebody else
not this guy he knew who what he wanted
right so he made the effort and i'm sure
that even if the andrew santino didn't
work out he would find another
another angle my point is is that you
know
that's just who he is i know what other
angle he would have taken after andrew
what
he would have used the mad tv connection
to the character that you played what
right
no who who did you play who did i play
where